by way of advice
in young people high school students
college students entering this world
full of automation
full of these complex um
labor markets and markets period what
would you uh what kind of advice would
you give to that person about how to
have a career
how to have a life they can be proud of
yeah i think you know this is such a
great question i don't um
it's okay to quote steve jobs right
[Laughter]
always yeah i mean so and i just heard
this recently it was a commencement
speech that he gave and i can't remember
where it was um and he was talking about
you know he you know he had famously
dropped out of school but continued to
take classes right um
and and he took a calligraphy class and
it influenced the design of the mac and
and sort of fonts and you know just was
was something that he had no
you know sense of what it was going to
be useful for and his his lesson was you
know you you can't connect the dots
looking forward you know looking back
you can see all the pieces
that sort of led you to where you ended
up and for me studying truck driving
like i mean i literally went to graduate
school because i was worried about
climate change and like you know i had a
whole other dissertation plan and then
was like driving home and like i had
read about all this management
literature and sort of like how you get
workers to work hard for my qualifying
exams and then read a popular article on
on satellite linked computers and the
story in the literature was you sort of
sense of autonomy and and i was like
well that monitoring must affect the
sense of autonomy and it's just this
question that i found interesting and it
never in a million years that i ever
thought i was gonna like study you know
spend 15 years of my life studying truck
driving um
and it was like if you were to map out a
career path in academia or research like
you know you would you would do none of
the things that i that i did that many
people advise me against where like you
can't like go spend a year working as a
truck driver you know like that's crazy
or you know you can't you know spend all
this time trying to write like one huge
book and you know um so
if i could just interrupt what what
what was the fire that got you to take
the leap and go and work as a truck
driver and go interview truck drivers
this is what a lot of people would be
incapable of doing just took took that
leap what the heck what the heck is up
with your mind that allowed you to take
that big leap so i think it's probably
like
tolkien and
you know i mean i think
yeah teenager you know i yeah i sort of
uh adopted some sense of needing to you
know heroically go out in the world and
and you know um which i've done at
various points in my life and like
looking back in absolutely stupid ways
um that you know where i could have
completely ended up dead and traumatized
my my family including like i took a
couple week trip in the pacific um like
solo trip and a kayak and basically my
kayaking experience up till that you
know point had been you know on a fairly
calm lake and like class one solo trip
on a kayak in the pacific yeah yeah so i
was working i was working on forestry
issues
and we were starting a campaign up in
really remote british columbia and i i
was like okay if i'm gonna work on this
i've gotta actually go there myself and
see what this is all about and see
whether it's worth like devoting my sort
of you know life right now too
and just drove up there with this kayak
and you know put into the pacific and um
it was insane you know like the tides
are huge and you know there there was
one point in which i was going down a
fjord and two fjords kind of came up and
there was a cross channel
and i had hit the timing completely
wrong and the tide was sort of rushing
up like you know rivers in these you
know two fjords and then
coming through this cross channel and
met and created this giant standing wave
that i had to paddle through um and now
actually very recently i've gone out on
whitewater with some people who know
what the hell they're doing and i
realized like
just how absolutely stupid
and and you know ill-fit i was but
that's just
that i think i've always had that were
you afraid
when you had that wave before that wave
scared the out of me yeah okay what
about
taking a leap and becoming a trucker
yeah there was some nervousness for sure
i mean and you know i guess my advantage
as an ethnographer is i i grew up in a
a blue collar environment you know again
all my um
ancestors are factory workers so i can
move
through spaces um i i'm really
i feel comfort i can become comfortable
in lots and lots of places you know not
everywhere but you know along class
lines for sort of white you know even
white ethnic workers like that's you
know
i can move in those spaces fairly easily
i mean not entirely there was one there
was one time where i was like okay you
know and i grew up around people worked
on cars i'd been to drag races in nascar
and um and i'd been to you know colgate
university and so i'd and i think that
was probably my initial training was you
know being this just working class kid
who ends up in this
you know sort of blue blood small
liberal arts college and just feeling
like
you know both having the entire world
opened up to me like philosophy and
buddhism and things that i had never
heard of you know and just became
totally obsessed with and just like you
know just following my interest but also
culturally perhaps didn't feel like you
fit in
feeling like just a fish out of water i
just you know but and at the same time
that
you know sort of drove me in the sense
that it drove an opening of my mind
because i couldn't understand it you
know i was like i didn't know that this
world existed i don't understand
and i think maybe that's where my real
first step in trying to understand other
people because they were my friends you
know i mean they were my teammates i
played lacrosse in college like you know
i was close to people who came from such
different backgrounds than i did and i
just
i was so confused you know and so i
think i i learned to learn um and then
you know sort of went from there and
then developed your fascination with
people and the funny thing is
you went from trucking now to autonomous
trucks i mean just speaking of not being
able to connect the dots and
you know your life in the next 10 years
could take very interesting directions
this is very difficult to first of all
us meeting is a funny little
thing given
the things i'm working on with robots
currently but you know it may not relate
to trucks at all
there's uh
at a certain point autonomous trucks are
just robots
and then it starts getting into a
conversation about the roles of robots
in society yeah and uh
and the roles of humans and robots and
that interplay
is right up your alley
yeah as somebody who deeply cares about
humans and have somehow found themselves
studying robots yeah no it's crazy i
mean even four four or five years ago i
i would if you had asked me if i was
going to be studying trucking still i
would have said no
and so my advice is i think if i was
going to give advice you know um is you
know you can't connect the dots looking
forward you just got to follow what
interests you you know and
and i think we we we downplay right that
when we when we talk to you know kids
especially you know if you have some
bright gifted kid that gets identified
as like oh you could go somewhere then
we're like we feed them stuff and like
we'll learn the piano and learn another
language right to learn robotics
and then we tell other kids like oh
learn a trade you know like figure out
what's going to pay well and not that
there's anything against traits i think
everyone should learn like manual skills
to make things i think it's incredibly
satisfying and and wonderful and we need
more of that but also you know tell you
know all kids it's okay to like take a
class in something random that you don't
think you're going to get any economic
return on
because maybe you will end up going into
a trade but that class that you took in
studio art is going to mean that you
know you you look at buildings
differently right or you end up sort of
putting your own stamp on you know
woodworking you know and just
i think that's the key is like follow
you know
it's cheesy because everybody says
follow your passion but you know if we
we say that and then we just you know
the the
90 of what people hear is you know
what's the return on investment for that
you know it's like you're a human being
like things interest you music interests
you literature interests you video games
interest you like follow it you know go
grab a kayak and go into the position go
do something real don't do that
go do something stupid and uh something
you'll regret a lot later my foremother
thank god she didn't know
you